Ryan Morrison spends a lot of time home
alone
his daughter is at preschool his wife
has gone back to work the family barely
makes ends meet
the bank has only deferred their loans
until the end of the month as a Drilling
Engineer Ryan did well out of the oil
boom in the North Sea but before he and
his family had even moved into their new
house he lost his job in June 2015 I was
told that you know there was no future
future work for me at the company we
much agreed that you know I would move
on you know thinking they know I could a
good level experience at that point I
thought you know I could put my CV out
to various court you know contractors
very various agencies but that was
almost a year ago and his chances of
finding a job here in Aberdeen are
looking increasingly slim every day he
trolls the internet for jobs he's been
off at work in Qatar but the project has
been postponed for at least a year
because of the low oil price and anyway
what about his new house many in the
neighborhood are in a similar position
the house just there to our to our left
is exactly the same house and you know
since the oil price has dropped so as
the house prices and the house there is
now fifty thousand pounds cheaper than
what it was eight months ago when we
purchased the house
oil and gas have been the dominant
industries in Aberdeen for years global
prices are now down to around $35 a
barrel barely more than production costs
here in the North Sea companies are
making cuts and delaying investments
there have been 70,000 layoffs in
Britain's oil industry in the last few
years highly qualified highly
specialized workers facing an uncertain
future Aberdeen is one of the World Cups
when it comes to oil and gas is hugely
important
please don't only support any activities
in North Sea the thought has been
exports from here across the world so it
is a real real big impact here - North
Sea know it sees more than hire caustic
basins - operated and of course when the
revenue falls away we can't simply just
adjust fast enough to get a price now to
make sure that the fields here are
competitive in a world environment many
people are giving up on the industry
michelle has lost her job twice now
she's setting up her own business
she's renovated an old shop and in a few
days she'll be opening her takeaway and
cafe here we are taking a lot of work to
get here we're nearly there but I'm very
glad to be I have to thought the gas
industry it certainly doesn't seem to be
improving so I feel like I've made the
right decision so far this customer is
looking for a free meal this is one of
Aberdeen's food distribution centres two
years ago they dispensed a total of ten
thousand food parcels a year that figure
has gone up to thirty thousand over the
last six to nine months we've noticed an
increase or beta a small minority of our
total if there's been an increase and
what you may describe is casualties from
the oil industry
it's the lovely light that earnt
aberdeen the nickname the Silver City
but for the time being its days in the
Sun are over boarded up shop fronts are
scattered along Union Street
Aberdeen's main shopping street and for
sale signs are sprouting up all over the
city's attractive residential
neighborhoods it's no longer just people
in the oil and gas industry who are
feeling the pinch
it's oil and gas reserves were a
significant factor in Scotland's push
for independence the no side won in a
referendum in 2014 but should Britain
vote for a brexit in June another
Scottish independence referendum will be
on the cards if there was a brexit
caused by an English majority voting
Scotland owed Scotland having voted to
remain in the EU then I think there
would definitely be a Scottish and a
second Scottish referendum and I doubt
very much that the oil price would play
a huge role or not Ryan has decided to
take a job in sales and to get a masters
degree hoping it might improve his
employment prospects now and then he
visits the port and looks out to sea you
know it makes me feel feel feel sad
because you know this is this is a boom
in town you know it's the oil capital of
Europe you know when things are going to
burn oil prices high you know this this
place is buzzing you know lots and lots
of activity going around the city and
it's sad to see you know very little no
vessels in the harbor no not a lot of
activity going
as the Sun sets on northeast Scotland
there's a palpable sense that the gold
rush is over